very top thing that men value above all
thing is sexual Purity we do not want to
imagine the woman we love taking a shot
on the face or getting dominated by any
other dude or you know being a part of a
gang bang or whatever goes on those
sororities we don't want to deal with
that it's not our ideal you would do it
to the other women that's what it's
called
so the average guy the average guy hold
on hold on the average guy which you
girls most likely ignore doesn't do that
ignore so
who gets the coverage is the top G's
that can get anything so most guys want
to be like that but you have to
understand they're adapting to the
market most guys are young and they
start they they start off really sweet
and what they're doing is they're
looking for a young wife that wants to
get married they're trying to treat her
well and they find out that when they
treat girls well they don't get laid